- Ah, Europe. Home of Florida football.
Nothing says Munich like the Tampa Bay Buccaneers.
- [German fan:] It's a famed American
hogskin player!
- Ugh, this happens everywhere I—
- Geno Smith!
- It's Eugene Smith!
- It's all about the team, baby. Isn't that right, Tyler Lockett?
- You know my name? Wow.
Russ always said that's what our numbers were for.
- They should call me Kenneth Dancer.
- Another.
- It's OK, Tom.
- Want me to fight 'em?
- So, get this. I told Geno the route to the biergarten...
...and he actually followed it.
- Woo!
- No one beats me at hanging out.
- [All gasping]
- Carbs!
- Not a single one of my seven rings is worth more than this pretzel!
Let's f--king gooo!
- Don't worry, it's no longer Danger-Russ.
- He has the best foot, so he is the best footballer.
- Nah, nah, nah.
- That could not matter less.
- Ugly Americans.
- So how do you keep getting better as you get older?
- The trick is to get the hell away from New Jersey.
- Hey, look, Gronk!
- Not every white guy with a beard is Gronk.
Oh, wait, that is Gronk.
- Prost!
- [Broadcaster 1:] And nobody showed up today except for the kickers.
- [Broadcaster 2:] Three points?! That's so many.
Field goooooooal!
- And Mariota with a five yard pass to...
...I don't know, I don't care. To take the lead over the coachless Panthers.
[sigh]
Goddammit, I'm Al Michaels, and that used to mean something.
- That's right, Al.
Also check out Amazon's Thursday Night Football Basketball Football.
Finally, basketball players talking over football about basketball and maybe football.